Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy arminia Fernández
comenzamos
México se ha mantenido en el tope de la
lista de los países más peligrosos para
el ejercicio del periodismo durante años
según la organización reporteros Sin
fronteras 17 periodistas fueron
asesinados en México en 2022 en Tijuana
en la frontera con Estados Unidos en
enero de 2022 en menos de una semana
asesinaron a dos periodistas Margarito
Martínez y Lourdes Maldonado Lourdes
contaba con medidas de protección
otorgadas por el estado de Baja
California Al momento de ser ejecutada
frente a su domicilio los periodistas
hacen llamados constantes de ayuda pero
parece no ser escuchados el gobierno
mexicano lo sigue estigmatizando se
encuentran atrapados entre el mundo de
la política y el crimen organizado que
muchas veces trabajan de la mano
nuestros reporteros lorrasco biliar y
Matthew coman visitaron Tijuana y nos
contarán en el siguiente reportaje como
los periodistas no tienen garantías para
informar ante la desprotección e
impunidad
[Música]
son las 10 de la noche en las calles de
Tijuana
bueno en esta ocasión me encuentro con
un macabro hallazgo registrado en el
puente peatonal Sobre la avenida y
Colonia del mismo nombre Sánchez taboada
a un costado del Kalimán una noche como
cualquier otra para Arturo que se dedica
a cubrir escenas del crimen en 2022 hubo
alrededor de 2.000 crímenes en Tijuana
actos pensados para sembrar el terror en
la ciudad es un brazo y una pierna esa
información que nos ha tenido y el
famoso narco mensaje colgado desde el
puente peatonal
pues ahí pueden observar ustedes no hay
acceso vehicular de ambos sentidos todo
tráfico está siendo desviado buscar
alguna otra ruta una excelente noche
para todo el público de blanco y negro
noticias informó Arturo Rosales Arturo
vende sus fotos como independiente y
grababa en directo para las redes
sociales se llevaba bien con Margarito
Martínez que también era fotógrafo fue
asesinado el 17 de enero de 2022 en
frente de su casa constantemente nos
topábamos en los hechos violentos De
hecho si él estuviera en vida Ahorita lo
tuviera aquí Margarito fue la primera
víctima del año más letal para la prensa
mexicana menos de una semana después de
su muerte en la misma ciudad otra
periodista fue alcanzada por las balas
de los asesinos a sueldo Lourdes
Maldonado dos historias muy diferentes
pero con el mismo final trágico Lourdes
se dio a conocer en 2019 durante una
conferencia de prensa del presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
vengo también aquí para pedirle apoyo
ayuda y Justicia laboral porque satemo
por mi vida que se trata de un personaje
fuerte en política que no pretende
pagarme ni mucho menos ya también tiene
un Amparo pero lo hago porque se trata
de su senador con licencia de su súper
coordinador de delegaciones y su
candidato próximo candidato a la
gubernatura de Baja California
licenciado Jaime Bonilla le voy a pedir
a Jesús
Ramírez que es el coordinador de
comunicación social que te atienda para
que se pida justicia que no haya
influyentismo
durante seis años Lourdes denunció ante
la justicia y a través de los medios al
antiguo gobernador de Baja California y
empresario Jaime Bonilla lo acusaba de
evasión fiscal y de múltiples
infracciones laborales
Sonia de anda coordinadora de un
colectivo de periodistas de Tijuana
seguía el caso de cerca Lourdes me busca
en marzo del año pasado
me dice que alguien le disparó a su
carro y ella inmediatamente menciona
Jaime Bonilla Valdez dice Bonilla me
está amenazando Porque yo lo estoy todos
los días soy muy dura en mis críticas en
un programa que hacía en redes sociales
desde la cocina de su casa entonces
ahorita como gobernador mientras estuvo
en el poder ha estado haciendo todo tipo
de convenios con medios de comunicación
para acabar de hundir y fregarse a todos
los periodistas que el miércoles
anterior se había parado en las afueras
de pcn de la empresa de Jaime Bonilla y
le había gritado que iba a tomar control
de la iban a embargar la caja de la
empresa y que ella iba a exhibir la
manera en la que Jaime Bonilla no paga
impuestos no le paga seguro social a los
trabajadores de cómo evade las cosas por
lo de la oficina y me tienen que
entregar los papeles para que yo lo
revise y yo los denuncie por
particularidades que se han cometido en
esa empresa
cuatro días después Lourdes Maldonado
fue asesinada a tiros delante de su casa
fuimos a la sede de la empresa psn donde
trabajó Lourdes tres personas fueron
acusadas por su presunta participación
en el crimen pero hasta el momento Jaime
Bonilla no ha sido interrogado por la
justicia
Pues el orden Maldonado no hay mucha
historia ella
trabajó en mi empresa yo la conocía muy
poco yo era diputado federal cuando ella
la reclutaron aquí y supe que ha habido
una una diferencia entre ella y que era
director se fue y de Mando Esa es la
historia de ella y este pues nos dolió
mucho que le pasara lo que le pasó
pero la fiscalía tiene toda la
información y el presidente dijo que iba
a haber a investigar y creo que lo hizo
por su cuenta a nosotros Nunca nos
vinieron a preguntar nada al preguntarle
al fiscal del Estado sobre los avances
de la investigación afirmó que está
esperando el momento oportuno tenemos el
impedimento desde luego de la situación
de
pues el fueros que con el que cuenta por
el cargo público que este se está
desarrollando Pero esto no quiere decir
que la investigación no se pueda o no se
deba de avanzar y queremos dejarlo muy
claro estamos investigándose de
investigación también Margarito también
sabía que estaba amenazado por el crimen
organizado y por una de la información
que libran los carteles de la droga
desde hace algunos años en Tijuana han
aparecido decenas de perfiles
supuestamente informativos en las redes
sociales algunos comunican datos poco
fiables simples rumores acusaciones sin
pruebas textos sin firmar imposible
saber quién está detrás de las
publicaciones Arturo las ha visto
multiplicarse con preocupación los
límites entre periodismo y propaganda se
han vuelto peligrosamente borrosos
es reconocible el medio no no colaboro
con ellos para nada porque la mayoría de
las páginas que se dicen ser un medio de
comunicación un medio informativo este
no tienen página web
puro Facebook puro Facebook y tú suben
sus notitas mal escritas no pues es que
estas fotos se filtran puede ser de
cualquier corporación de gobierno la
gran diferencia
de este disque medio informativo Pues
nos publicó unas fotos pues muy cercanas
no tan cerquitas que ningún
fotoperiodista puede arrimarse tanto
como esta página hay como unas unas
veinte aquí en Tijuana más
mal informando a la gente
publicando las fotos sin censura algunas
cuentas parecen estar en una Cruzada
contra un cartel como Tijuana en guerra
que durante meses solo habló de los
actos de la banda del líder criminal
cabo 20 por publicar fotos
extremadamente violentas de las escenas
del crimen la cuenta ganó un público
mucho más amplio que algunos de los
medios tradicionales más de 150.000
Seguidores la provocación vende
Margarito firmaba sus fotos y solo
trabajaba para medios pero un día
discutió con un hombre que lo estaba
grabando en directo y lo acusaba sin
tener pruebas ni el Halcón de la Sánchez
ni nada güey Yo no tengo medios
escondidos que es Tijuana en guerra y
quemando malandros como los que traes tú
eh yo lo único que te pido conmigo no te
metas
Ahí está para que vean este este señor
es el que maneja Tijuana en guerra
quemando malandros trae muchos medios de
comunicación falsos que se la lleva
subiendo notas falsas también el video
tuvo miles de vistas el hombre que
discutió con Margarito es Ángel Peña
tiene una página en Facebook llamada
Ángel le informa y Desde hacía meses
despertaba la sospecha de los
periodistas en Tijuana por sus prácticas
poco éticas y la manera en la que Ángel
Peña se comportaba en esas épocas no era
como la de un periodista y Margarito
Margarito empezó a alertarnos en el
colectivo de que Ángel Peña era un
halcón
así le llaman a estos personas que
disfrazados de periodistas Pues están
avisándole a los grupos criminales donde
está la policía Cómo se están moviendo
si pusieron un
retén Ángel Peña se paraba en esos esos
filtros
separa hacia la transmisión en vivo
enfocaba los rostros de los policías
enfocaba las placas de las camionetas
los números de las de las unidades y eso
no lo hacemos los periodistas menos de
un mes después de esa violenta discusión
Margarito fue asesinado unos instantes
después del drama sus amigos se
reunieron en el lugar del crimen y en
eso empiezo a ver que empiezan a
comentar los compañeros en el colectivo
Aquí está Ángel Peña está transmitiendo
y es donde me arrancó
vergüenza estar aquí maldito
somos libertad soy periodista A
diferencia de ustedes que se dedican a
promover las páginas de narcos tú
acusaste a Margarita
los meses siguientes el arresto y la de
varios presuntos responsables del
asesinato pareció confirmar que el autor
intelectual fue efectivamente El cabo
veinte el líder criminal contra el que
se dirigían los ataques de las
publicaciones de Tijuana en guerra nos
pusimos en contacto con los
administradores de la página que siempre
permanecieron anónimos pero no
contestaron a nuestra solicitudes de
entrevista otra noche más con un
promedio de cinco asesinatos diarios en
las calles de Tijuana siempre hay
trabajo entre las escenas del crimen
Arturo recorre las calles como taxista
para llenar las horas muertas en esta
ocasión me encuentro en un hallazgo de
restos humanos ubicados sobre la calle
octava
esta vez otras personas llegaron primero
imposible distinguir a un periodista de
un simple espectador un influenciador o
un informante de Cartel se acaba de
reportar el hallazgo de una cabeza
cercenada una cabeza humana tirada aquí
en la vía pública A las afueras de una
escuela primaria te mando un saludo a
todas las personas que se están
conectando a esta transmisión en vivo
Ángel Ibarra te mando un gran saludo
Maribel Alvarado ya son 70 muertes en lo
que va en escasos diez días de este mes
Perdón
78 ya le vamos pegando los 80 Cómo la
ven tenemos un encuentro inesperado a la
escena también llegó Ángel Peña el
hombre que acusó a Margarito Martínez de
estar detrás de las páginas sospechosas
de Facebook no contestó a nuestra
solicitudes de entrevista cuando
Tratamos de contactar si usted tiene
problemas son muy aparte
si él tiene problemas igual es muy ajeno
a lo mío yo nomás ve de hecho Yo casi no
le hablo
ya he tenido muchas amenazas por parte
del por parte de los dos Entonces yo
estoy entre la espada entre menos me
metan problemas para mí es mejor y las
calles de Tijuana todo está en la
penumbra imposible saber con quién se
habla la única opción es mantener la
distancia y ser discreto sí tengo miedo
Soy ser humano pero pues Alguien tiene
que sacar el trabajo
de la información de la nota policiaca
en la ciudad de Tijuana en un país donde
la impunidad en los casos de asesinatos
de periodistas es casi absoluta el resto
del autor intelectual de un crimen sería
una señal de esperanza porque hasta el
momento las medidas de protección que
tienen los periodistas incluida Sonia de
anda no han dado resultado de que los
crímenes de periodistas se deben de
perseguir con toda la fuerza del Estado
para desalentar los ataques a
periodistas no es la solución que nos
pongan un agente ministerial o un
policía detrás de nosotros Porque el día
que nos quieren matar ha sucedido
primero Matan al escolta y después te
matan a ti
y tenemos que sembrar ese mensaje el que
toca uno de nosotros nos toca a todos no
hay de otra
Y si para eso hay que derramar sangre
aquí está la mía y la que sigue
las fronteras del mundo de la
información están lejos de ser tan
nítidas como el muro que separa Tijuana
de Estados Unidos además de las amenazas
del crimen organizado y de la corrupción
los periodistas mexicanos ahora
enfrentan otro enemigo aún más difícil
de identificar la desinformación entre
estas arenas movedizas 17 de ellos
perdieron la vida en 2022
hasta aquí reporteros en la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]